thank you absolutely gorgeous as always
oh thank you very much handsome i like
the her what's that what's this your her
as per you that's what you call the
little the wave in the hair is the her
yeah you're her uh-huh
wow no one's ever done it back that's
incredible
thank you
thank you so much too you know i'm gonna
did that would come across as pervy my
ha ha
it sounded a little
okay
no you are um you know it's so nice to
have you on the show and i was i was
thinking about this today and then
confirmed when you come out here you're
you're very elegant you're very elegant
woman you're very beautiful posture as
well i find you always are whenever
you're on the show you're you you're
very statuesque and the way you sit is
this something you think about at all um
i actually was really funny when i was
doing transpress i was looking into a
lot of what postures and what our
physicality says about ourselves and
i really like actually this idea that
you know we kind of when we're kind of
down or whatever we project this idea of
our internal space yes but what i think
is interesting on the flip side of that
is that you can actually use your
posture then to change your mood so in
that same idea of like smiling and make
you feel better like your body doesn't
know the difference when you're watching
a movie and you know you're seeing
lights in front of you but your heart
starts racing and yes you know you don't
know the reality necessarily so i
watched this ted talk and this woman was
talking about it fake it until it's real
yeah and you can go up there and like do
like a like a wonder woman pose like
when you stand out there like
like before you go into a big meeting or
an audition by having that heroic
position
because you've got the clark kent thing
going on but when you stand up and do
your superman right like this you know
what i find is that when you when i
stand when i'm sitting and slumped over
i feel like a very small person
but if i interviewed people like this
doesn't matter
i just i think of you and like
now you see me differently confidence
tell us rosario what's the story here
what do you want to know anything yeah
anything well okay that's that's why i
should do the show from now on yes
please um you know
i was told that you went to
just don't wear shorts
i'm going to do it wearing super short
shorts
really short um
yeah it's going to be the creepiest and
i'm going to get a big perm for my hair
i don't know why or a sweat band right
there
gonna be like a late 70s gym coach uh
love it um workouts oh yeah i work at
any time you must work working out a lot
uh no not not so much
i do
constantly i don't know where i went
with there i want to ask you about um
that was fantastic by the way you must
be you must be doing yoga and everybody
in this house
jokes one of your lamest jokes yeah sure
why not okay so do you know any good
veterinarians no because these puppies
are sick
that's good
i like how your lamest joke did better
than anything i've had